luis and kate have two video games they
want to play
they plan to spend exactly 45 minutes
playing the two games they want to use
an equation to express the relationship
between the number of minutes they spend
playing super bologna man and the number
of minutes they spend playing you have
to cut the wire
can this relationship be represented
using a linear equation so let's see if
it can so let's define some variables
for let's define one variable for the
amount of time
the amount the number of minutes so the
number of minutes they spend playing
super bologna man let's define that as
well let's just say that's x so x is
equal to time
playing
playing
bologna man i'll write bologna right
here
bologna man
and let's define
y
as
y
is equal to the number of minutes they
spend playing you have to cut the wire
so it's time
time playing
i'll just call it the cut the wire i'll
just call it wire for short
so if we have the minutes they play time
playing bologna the time playing cut
your wire if i were to add those two
together so if i say x
plus y i'll write the plus in a neutral
color x plus
y
what does this need to be equal to
the time i play bologna man plus the
time i play have to cut the wire well if
i add them together they they want to
spend exactly 45 minutes playing both
games so this is going to be equal to
45 minutes
now we have set up an equation that that
represents the that relates the time
playing bologna man and the time playing
you have to cut or you have to cut the
wire but now we have to think about is
this a linear relationship
so one way to think about it is the real
giveaway for a linear relationship is if
you could write it in the traditional
form of a line
so if you can write it in the y is equal
to mx plus b form where m is the slope
of the line and b is the y-intercept so
let's see if we can do that
well if we want to do that here we could
just subtract x from both sides you
subtract x from both sides you get so
let's subtract an x over here let's
subtract an x over here so negative x
plus this and then subtract an x there
well that's going to cancel and you're
going to be left with and i'm going to
try to write it in this form right over
here
y
is equal to
45 actually let me do that same color
just to make it not be confusing
y
is
equal to
and i'll write the negative x first
because we have the x term right over
here first so y is equal to negative x
negative x plus 45
plus
45. all i did is i switched these two
terms around but you see here it has
that form and you might say wait what is
m here i see that b is 45 well if i
write negative x that's the same thing
as writing negative
1 x so this is definitely a line i was
able to write it in this form right over
here so can this represent can this
relationship be represented using a
linear equation
absolutely
absolutely yes